tony is on the line in Illinois hi Tony
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you sir better than I deserve
what's up fantastic let me let me start
by saying thank you for taking my call
my wife and I were looking at ourselves
in a really tough financial spot we made
some really stupid decisions financially
and when I got fed up with it I went to
my aunt who was also my godmother and
she I was gonna bring tools I could I
could find to fix our problem and she
warned me your total money makeover and
my wife and I are raving and and we're
gizelle intense we're ready
and so we've saved $1,000 and we made
the really tough decision for my wife to
go back to work after being a
stay-at-home mom you're sticking care of
our two boys so now that she's back at
work and we we have a snowball effect in
full action here we she is eligible for
a car package at work which will give us
five hundred bucks a month including a
gas card and paid for car insurance with
her job but that means she has to trade
in her her old car that's paid off in
order to get a car that's ten years over
newer and risk take on potentially a car
payment so I wanted to see what what I
got a what answers I got to give you to
find out you know what I got a handle
this how do that because this on okay
we're not taking on a car payment under
any circumstance so that means we're not
doing this right now you know and there
the downside of this is if she doesn't
work there anymore and you took out a
car payment that was supposed to be paid
by this car package she didn't get the
car package you more you still got the
car payment right and so she quits or
gets fired or changes jobs or whatever
things happen so no we're not taking out
a car payment based on a car allowance
ever and I certainly wouldn't do it here
now so she has a car and she can get
back and forth to work correct and what
does she make
she makes 45 thousand a year okay
and what do you make 55
okay so we have a hundred thousand
dollar household income and how much
debt do you have not counting your home
we are renting including the other hall
the other car which has got ten thousand
left on it we have a total about 15,000
and debt okay all right and so how
quickly making a hundred thousand
dollars a year
will you have fifteen thousand dollars
paid off about three months we can
probably net thirty five hundred dollars
a month with our new income after our
bills are paid
how long after that does she plan to
work indefinitely
it's we plan to make it a career and
once we get to that step we're both
going to jump on that 15 percent of our
income for our 401k so we're excited
about that step when it comes okay so
the idea of her being home with the boys
is on hold
yes my mom is watching our boys while we
both work now and so this is a permanent
decision not a temporary decision to get
out of debt yes until my youngest is in
full-time school that's that's a
decision okay all right okay cool all
right
so your debt free in three months so
what you said yes sir okay and then the
next step is to build the emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses and
then what is her current car worth her
car probably worth two or three thousand
dollars at the most okay and they want
you to buy a two year old or a newer car
and what was the other stipulation on it
or two year old or newer um ten year ten
years older no ten years old or newer
okay
yes and what was the other stipulation
anything no that's it you know with if
we with our tax return coming in soon
we're getting about $8,000 mm-hmm so we
could use that definitely towards a car
and there are more that yeah yeah no
kidding okay so
yummy eight thousand and three thousand
eight thousand and three thousand eleven
thousand you have to have your emergency
fund him so let me back up okay what
would I do I would get out of debt I
would build the emergency fund and then
I would safe to move up in car beyond
the emergency fund buying a car is not
an emergency and you would not upgrade
your in your case so I would not upgrade
a car which is not emergency until after
you have your emergency fund in place in
your debt free so when your tax return
comes in is probably not going to the
car it's probably going to the emergency
fund right okay then we're going to use
the fact that we have no payments in the
world a newfound control over money
called a budget this unity this doubling
of income because she's gone back to
work all of these blessings that are in
your life mathematically to build up
some money and go pay cash for a car and
move up in car
my guess is about September she's gonna
be buying at twelve fourteen thousand
our car you pay cash for with a three
thousand dollar idea and that and and
then you can take the car package but
we're not going into debt to get the car
package right too many downsides plus
you kind of have to make this decision
is our Edna you know am I gonna live the
old way or the new way because there's
kind of no middle ground the ish thing
just doesn't work you know and that's
that's why I feel conflicted I'm looking
at all the tools I can yeah that's cool
yeah well the confliction the conflicted
feeling was accurate because if you were
you know getting ready to go
perpendicular to the new things you were
learning so well done sir well done you
guys are in the heart of it man you
fighting it scratch and claw already got
a game we were ready I can't wait so I
think you're gonna be out of debt in
three months you're gonna use your tax
return gesture w-4 so that doesn't
happen again use your tax return to
build up that emergency fund then you're
gonna start saving for a car probably
around September three thousand dollar
trade-in because it won't go down in
value much between now and then and
about a ten thousand dollar cash above
your emergency fund with that puts her
under thirteen fourteen thousand dollar
car all that and that's the plan so well
done that's cool I like that a lot